let's talk about people who go back home
quote unquote to regroup
i heard an interview with danny mcbride
he talked about being in his mid-20s i
think he came out here
la hit him pretty hard he went back home
to virginia
to regroup then he came back
when you go back to regroup what would
you recommend to other people
if they're in the same shoes maybe
they're done with the industry maybe
they want some time off
well my experience is
that when you go away and it doesn't
just have to be home
i would recommend to a lot of people
they go live in paris for a year
you know regroup that way recharge you
know
just fill your senses in your sight with
you know the
the lusciousness of the world wherever
that is for you
uh but don't not allow yourself to do it
because you're afraid you're going to
miss an audition
do you know you're afraid oh you're i'm
going to miss a job if i leave
i won't be ready and the truth of the
matter is
what most people find is that their
peers that they
left are pretty much right in the exact
same place
they were when the person left a year
earlier
so i just want people not to think that
they're missing something
they're not they're adding something now
how you maintain
touch with the business i say go back
and
refill yourself craft wise i mean
there's a lot that we're
responsible for doing in terms of
finding things that carbonate us
and home is a pretty rich place for that
both good and bad
you know there's a wonderful acting
teacher larry moss and larry would
always say to us that
your mineral gold gold the mineral
is your wound that's what you want to
work from
and most of us in this life try to cover
that wound up
and it's the actor's job to touch it and
reveal it
and you know home for most of us was
where that wound started so
in that regard i think i would go back
and write
be awake walk take a great long walks
you know and understand and look at vast
spaces
look at expanses look at the ocean or
look at the forest or whatever it is
because we need to
we need we need a sensation the
sensation that there's something larger
than we are we can get very very small
in our
you know world
you